welcome back and we are back with
stephen miller the founder of america
first
legal and stephen you uh explained title
42
really well and we appreciate that
because this is the crux of
the uh really deterrent for people to
come and there isn't any deterrent right
now
john solomon is reporting that there is
a bipartisan call for
biden to appoint a new border czar
apparently uh
kamala harris being criticized as she
continues to search for the root
causes of of this illegal migration
representative henry cuellar and senator
lindsey graham
are asking president biden to appoint
former homeland security secretary jay
johnson
to a special executive position to
manage the border crisis according to
john solomon
your thoughts on what kamala harris is
doing in the face of all of this
yes well for one thing i think it's
pretty clear that
the vice president's political ambitions
are effectively destroyed as a result of
her administration of the border
but it's important for people to keep in
mind that
she is not the one making these policy
decisions these policy decisions are
being made
by the faceless radicals throughout the
body administration who are running the
show
their white house staff their dhs staff
most of whom
will never be known to the american
public who are making these
truly truly deadly decisions that are
resulting in drugs disease
crime as well as just large-scale
illegal immigration that drains our
finances
and that destroys american jobs and
wealth and so i completely agree
the vice president should be replaced
but ultimately
she's only being used as the fall person
behind a scheme that staff has put
together